For substitution ciphers rather
than trying all possible keys,
we can use the frequency of letters.
For example, here is the frequency
distribution of English letters.
Now let's do an exercise together.
With the frequency distribution
of English letters,
can we figure out the plain text for
this following cipher text?
To start we notice that the letter
Q here in the cipher text
is the most frequent.
And we know that in plain text English,
the letter E is the most frequent.
So, there's a high probability that
Q is in fact the plain text letter E.
Then we can look at the three-letter
words, for example, here and here.
Now we know that Q is in fact E.
So both end in E,
these two three-letter words.
So most likely one of them would be the,
T-H-E.
The other one would be are, A-R-E.
So here we're going to start to use
the knowledge of English language.
In other words,
what are the common words or
what are the legitimate words in English
to help us uncover the plain text?
For example,
we can see if we say H is A and R is T,
then we have a two letter word here, HR.
In this case, if H is A and
R is T, that would be at,
which is a commonly used
two letter word in English.
And also, if H is A,
then we have this three letter word
that has two letters the same.
So if H is A, then this can be all.
So we can continue with this process
by using our knowledge of the English
language to uncover the plain text.
Here we use both the frequency
distribution of the English letters and
our knowledge of English
words to help us.
If you continue with this process,
you should be able to uncover
this following plain text.
We will meet in the middle
of the library at noon,
all arrangements are made.
In practice,
in addition to the frequency
distribution of English letters,
we can also consider the frequency
of letter pairs, or even triples.